all the late-night talk show hosts for
the first time have band together to
roast president Trump for more on what
they're doing and why we're joined by
Fox News contributor New York Times
bestselling author the wheel Wilder
series Raymond Arroyo Raymond I saw the
triple boxes with Conan and and the
others and I was thoroughly non and not
interested but apparently everybody
else's well this is important let me
tell you well how this started Jimmy
Fallon came out to The Hollywood
Reporter and said he kind of backtracked
and apologized for having Donald Trump
on
he's been hazed for this much during the
campaign they said it humanized the
president then the president addressed
it in South Carolina watch Jimmy Fallon
the guy screws up my hair he apologized
for humanizing me can you add the poor
guy because now he's gonna lose all of
us if somebody would open a talk show at
night cuz the guy on CBS's is what a
low-life what a lowlife I mean honestly
are these people funny there's no talent
he's not they're not like talented
people Johnny Carson was talented okay
first of all you and I both love Johnny
Carson wouldn't be a great late-night
host he's he's off the cup but I'm gonna
just take a slightly different view of
the devil's advocate I don't think the
president should have elevated that by
attacking it because it elevates him now
the the late-night industrial complex
came together and they created this a
trifecta of attack on the president
watch did you see Trump's rally last
night nope me neither here just have
some pretty bad stuff about us really
that doesn't sound like him I heard you
say we're all no-talent low-lives lost
souls well that's not right that's Conan
[Applause]
Donald Trump the real-estate guy who
sell steaks he's president yeah how's he
doing not so good hey you still have to
lunch yeah boy you want to eat red hen
red hand funny there's no fun and
there's something else really sad here
we need as Americans a place that we can
unify and laughter comedy was that place
Jimmy Fallon was the last holdout in
late-night that kept politics on a low
sound like a back burner
he had funny at games he's silly goofy
that's gone up I have a friend who's
watched him every night since he
premiered she just told me I took him
off of my DVR and what's so crushing
about this he was that last bastion for
people and only a year ago last year he
said this to his colleague willie Geist
it's just not what I do I think it'd be
weird for me to start doing it now I
don't really even you know care that
much about politics I got to be honest I
love pop culture more than I love
politics I'm just not that brain you
know do you ever feel pressure to talk
about Donald Trump or to go political
you hear that noise no I mean I think
the other guys are doing it very well
when it's organic I'll dip into it as
well but I've always made jokes about
the president Fallon was really smart
there you bet I cut your audience in
half right well here's the problem I'll
tell you why he's doing it now and doing
these may of culpas cold Colbert was
beating him in the ratings 3.8 million
people tuning in so I went I dug up the
man we heard about earlier Johnny Carson
who talked to Barbara Walters about
politics and why he stayed away from it
in issue Oh watch I think one of the
dangers if you are a comedian which
basically I am
if you start to take yourself too
seriously
and start to comment on social issues
your sense of humor suffers somewhere
The Tonight Show basically is to amuse
people to make them laugh this is why he
presided over the most-watched talk show
of all time for more than 40 no one will
ever touch Carson because that era is
over could they go a week without Trump
I know she going a Trump die but not
mention a freak about it'll be funny
think about Carol Burnett who was his
contemporary she also kept politics out
of her show she could have done Nixon
sketches never did she was doing mrs.
Hugh Wiggins and Mama's family which 40
and 50 years later people are still
buying the DVLA Tyler Barrett Tyler
Perry when he does our favorite Madea
Madea stays away from my love Madea I
love all my dear because everybody can
laugh together around that we need
unifying comedy after this of comedy all
right Carson's right the humor suffers
and we don't need that anything it's not
just the worst offense it's not funny
well that's that is a brawl Conan's the
most funny in that boxes but Ramos
Seinfeld is speaking about this week
about the Rose Ann reboot so what what
does he say remember when I told you
this show when everybody was hailing it
oh this is great we all love it and I
said she's a loose cannon she's a little
crazy and ABC had to let her go now
Seinfeld is saying no they shouldn't
have done that
they should have recast the role of
Roseanne Connors with another actress
and then he added this controversial I
didn't see why it was necessary to fire
her why would you murder someone who's
committing suicide but I never saw
somebody in the retire career with one
button push that was fresh I think what
he was saying there it was a little
tongue in cheek was that the audience
should have decided what to do with
Roseanne maybe give her another chance I
don't know but you know Seinfeld has
always been on kind of the outside of
comedy he hates the PC culture and he
doesn't speak on college campuses won't
anything weird the bite but I don't know
if we have time now we have the play
this again for it dovetails back to what
Carson was saying about what how you
circumscribe unifying humor by getting
really political let's watch is the
climate worry you now I've seen
I talked to Chris Rock and Larry the
Cable Guy they don't even want to
college campuses anymore I hear that all
the time
III don't play colleges but I hear a lot
of people tell me don't go in their
colleges they're so PC they just want to
use these words that's racist that's
sexist that's prejudice he's old-school
in that and what I love Jerry Seinfeld
is doing a new season of his comedians
in cars getting coffee Jerry Lewis in
one of his last interviews is in the car
with Seinfeld cannot wait to see that I
promise you it will not be PC and it
probably won't people it's very Louis
smashed Obama pretty hard in your
interview but that was not that was not
in his comedy act that was in an
interview and I asked him about refugees
and he said are we felt about they're
not funny when all it is this Trump
Trump Trump it's not funny it's boring
well they become a political activist
and nobody wants to see they want to
laugh the other networks that nobody
watches all right Raymond awesome thank
you so much